you know the leader you know what mike
grebel's successful in tennessee ryan
freaking tanner hill because if marcus
mariota was still a quarterback i don't
know that they're playing this world
right now so which brings me to ryan
tannehill you know what he pro you know
what he's proved to me
stop talking to me about quarterbacks
and when i say stop talking to me i'm
talking about you i'm talking about any
quarterback whisperer out there any
so-called scouting expert don't talk to
me about what you think you know about
quarterbacks because nobody was checking
for ryan checking for ryan tannehill in
miami okay he goes there as a backup
last year takes him to the afc
championship game with 117 quarterback
rating
and fittingly they pay him 118 million
dollars in the off-season i don't know
if that's coincidental or not but they
pay 118 million dollars in off-season
and i'm like why are you paying ryan
tannehill 118 million dollars i know he
only do for like 200 yards last night
but that guy's really freaking good at
32 years old and he just goes to show
all of these people you know that mean
michael i wasn't seeing that meme on the
internet
look at these numbers you know those
that meme on the internet where there's
the guy walking down the street with his
girlfriend
but he's turned around oh yeah he's
grabbing that pretty girl walking by
yeah that's every team
with a quarterback that needs
development turned around looking at the
next hot thing coming up in the draft
okay everybody's like oh well this guy
trevor lawrence this guy's coming out
maybe we should you know throw in the
towel on the quarterback we got i mean
it really is it's an indictment of of
joe philbin and adam gase
okay we may get you later i was waiting
i was waiting
i was sitting dead red fast
come on go now get to it get to it
adam
if
gates
trying to get rid of sam darnold look at
ryan hill michael holly
yeah look i i think it really speaks to
what what gase did in miami more than
anything else because i think you look
at some of those guys who left who left
the miami dolphins when gates was there
and what they're doing right now i mean
a lot has been written on this there's
nothing new but
tana hill leaves there he goes to
tennessee
is wildly successful kenyon drake leaves
there he goes on he's got some success
so i think i think part of it is
where you are and the other part is
like we've seen this many times in
multiple sports
you go to a situation that is designed
for you or you just fit in and you can
thrive in miami
maybe they're trying to make ryan
tannehill into something that he wasn't
the guy started playing the position
late anyway
he was a wide receiver a late developing
quarterback
and so then you go there
and you try to turn him into like this
this drop back pastor who's going to be
throwing it 30 35 times a game and he's
going to develop at some perennial 4 500
4700 yard passer that's not who he is i
think he's in a great situation for him
right now so give mike rabel
credit for this
mike rabel and smith the offensive
coordinator give them both credit for
realizing what they had
in tannehill behind mariota and making
the switch
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports